I come into this video playing emj chav
checker off the sweetie the name may be
may be there sir and I am off the names
possible Scott Argentinian flag down
okay I don't want to take really okay ah
he can maybe kept you on c3 I forgot
about this post chanting yeah mm-hmm
this is a structure that I don't like
that much it's um it's nothing that I
really known okay I want to do something
directly am NOT not shuffle around I
hope this is a possibility and not
totally bad yeah it seems to be a valid
line in a way I said taking here yeah I
don't know should d 2 that's III
emphasis on this is not really great
I go Quincy to know maybe I can take on
f3m Camden Bishop f5 I but this is not
so bad actually then then the light
squares are really weak not maybe I
don't know it's a very weird position
type very unconventional just take take
on your form I don't know and I can
actually take now maybe is this an idea
damaging is pawn structure you cannot
castle then because of night f7 but ok i
don't i don't need to do it right now i
can still develop ok yeah I don't mind
that position so much it should be
should be ok really always weakening is
a king side quite quite clearly ok I'll
start with this then drop back to have
three Wow
it's really hard to believe I v5 this is
why it is hard to believe it should
really expose the skin position quite
clearly yet Bishop f5 I have to shoot d3
order or the exchange sack it's both
very promising Bishop d2 d3 is the
simplest simplest solution though yeah
and better I guess rook air-five GF
Queen takes it's not totally clear that
I have enough firepower quickly to to to
mate them I have that that's the scuba
shop g4 though as an idea if it's
interesting check check and Bishop to g4
yeah rook air-five GF Queen takes Queen
c3 and probably now come on this is this
is just a simple solution it leads to a
good position for wide and it's much
easier to play
no g5 is just hanging and that will get
them a strong attack without any
material without any material deficit
yeah I can take which is not bad but
better it's probably look everyone
getting the look into the place or that
look f8 is not possible Queen g7 desk we
need six check and there's always these
checks on the sixth-ranked Queen e7
Queen g6 checkers also winning with
raghav 7 coming they're here just this
one check and that's it it was strange
that he played the design every size H
takes g5 was our strange pretty clear
that this is not not working with Bishop
f6 and e5 his his King side is just just
very weak yeah we can look briefly at
the opening I really don't know the the
ins and outs of that probably some
normal move is better than you forward I
I don't know I wanted to open up the
center quickly this type of gambit play
maybe I'm here maybe you should just
take it I don't know a queen a fiber
certainly not bad it's not easy now to
cover this this is it's really really
not good I guess look strange at least
so I went here and here i was expecting
maybe it for him to take and this but
then I thought well Bishop d3 this if we
look at this position he always has a we
keep on and this is now really serious
without the light squared Bishop so I
thought this is maybe compensation may
be okay and here i get the porn back
without any
serious problem I think yeah I could
have taken here already on your five
maybe it may be possible but ok this is
this is probably probably ok are here
and teen Knight f3 is stronger according
to the engine I see em yeah this is in
fact stronger because of this beehive
idea this is a yeah really problematic
now he cannot go here because of e5 and
he's totally falling apart and if he
jacks there's again d 5 and this is
really tough to defend also aged 16 a
very good position for either this was
even better than my move and ta must
take with this of course neither three
Quincy 7 this is what I are thinking
then maybe night h4 now I'm intending
maybe to shift over but this is nothing
particularly great i mean yeah his King
side is a bit weak but it shouldn't be
decisive and here god this is so this is
just excellent for wide yeah computer
gives wider a win even him no defense
best defenses f5 which after is 60 ever
is terrible and this I just briefly want
to check if this is also winning yeah
computer wants to take on d6 with the
great position ok and e6 is also good
yeah e6 is also leading to a very strong
attack but this is not probably not
winning directly I thought your thought
at least here I was thinking that
probably there is the win yeah and in
fact stockfish she gives 0
it's probably just not enough you can't
always escape here with with the
perpetual but you have the rope hanging
end you have queen III check in the mix
so you don't have any given any move
that you can play this is this a shot
not really working unfortunately check
and wins public but this was just a
simple solution there's absolutely no
defense now g5 hangs and here Luke f1 is
is a flat-out win it looks like a
blunder here you create but there is no
defense if he does something its basic
you always this check and then the route
coming in with Queen f6 deciding the
issue okay well here here maybe the
caption 26 is also good not allowing
Queen B 1 but even that I should I think
should win if we look at this check can
I escape here maybe not young yeah I
probably must go back yeah well it's
winning in any case okay thanks for
watching